>> Such an honor to have Jon Kleinberg visit
us today for the distinguished lecture at MSR AI.
Jon is the Tisch University Professor in
the Departments of Computer Science
and Information Science at Cornell University.
His research focuses, as you all know,
on very interesting issues at
the interface of algorithms, networks,
and information with an emphasis on
the social and information networks that
underpin the web and other media.
We just came out of a fireside chat that will
be on hopefully edited and available soon,
where Jon talked about
his early days and
reflections and interest in law and mathematics.
And wondering if he'd ever
combine these things together and some issues that
might come to the fore some day while
staring at an Apple II Computer
and writing simple programs.
And the fact that
he discovered a few years later that this
is actually a field called computer science
that brought some of these ideas to life.
But probably, even back then, he had
no idea where things were going,
in terms of the work that though and
the challenges and opportunities we
now face as a community.
Jon's a member of the National Academy of Sciences,
National Academy of Engineering.
And the recipient of a fellowship from MacArthur,
Packard, Simons and the Sloan Foundation.
And he's won a number of prizes, the Harvey Prize,
the Nevanlinna Prize,
Newell Award and the ACM prize in computing.
Knowing a bunch about your work and following it closely,
I'm sure all of those prizes were well deserved.
So, Jon. Come on and speak.
>> All right. There's a badge there.
Great. Well, thanks very much for
the invitation to come speak here.
And it's been a really fun day getting to meet with
so many people whose work
I really admire and enjoy keeping up with.
So, I want to talk today about some work
I've been doing jointly with Sendhil Mullainathan,
a Behavioral Economist at
Harvard who have known for a long time.
And two of my PhD students;
Manish Raghavan and Maithra Raghu.
Thinking about issues in
this emerging space of
topics that goes under the name Algorithmic Fairness.
And the talk will really be
about some definitional questions.
And really a lot of focus will actually, in this work,
be about some of the aspects
where we take
different competing demands for what it would
mean for decision rule to be fair and try to
evaluate how these decisions
and these definitions interact with each other.
And I'll try to sort of highlight some things that I
think we learned that surprised us.
Once we sort of start to sort
out some of these definitions conceptual issues.
So, this actually started
from some work that Sendhil and I were doing
on human decision making and
really look at the intersection of algorithmic
and human decision making.
We were motivated by the fact that
in computer science and in the social sciences,
their activities that superficially look very different,
that syntactically have a surprising amount
in common with each other.
So, if I think about computer science,
a canonical sort of decision that
we've gotten very good at is the sort
of decision that you see embodied in
a ranking function or recommendation function.
So, this is a screenshot from
a tutorial blog post on Netflix,
showing how it's making recommendations.
And essentially from a huge amount
of data about a user, as all of you know,
it abstracts some kind of a sparse set of
features that's somehow a thin representation of this,
rich, living, breathing individual.
And it tries to
predict why am I going to like this movie.
It's going to assign
a probability estimate to that based on
data they have about them and
data they have about many other people.
And these kinds of activities in the online world are
things that we've developed a lot of
practice at refining and improving.
But meanwhile, in the offline world
as Sendhil proved to me,
there are activities that human beings are
doing that look somewhat similar, right?
So hiring, for example,
which superficially very different.
Certainly, each individual
decision there's more high stakes.
But we take an enviable job applicant who's a complex,
living, breathing human being.
They submit something like a resume,
CV, maybe a school transcript.
And some hiring committee looks at
this and decide will this person to be a good employee.
And in fact, part of
that decision is to make a prediction;
will they do well in the environment at our company?
Same thing happens with college admissions,
you take a college applicant,
you get some set of features about them and some,
committee make a decision which is in
part based on a prediction.
An estimate of their probability
of succeeding in this program.
Now, in the offline world,
these are relatively high stakes decisions compared with
ranking recommendation where maybe billions of
low stakes decisions are being made by the algorithm.
But fundamentally, they all sort of
follow this common pipeline, right?
We're mapping individual features to
an algorithm and some sort of predictions being made.
Here, I think of the prediction
as maybe a probability estimate.
I'm going to assign a probability or you,
about some future behavior.
Are you going to be in
the positive class or negative class?
Are you going to be a yes or a no?
Right? Are you going to like the movie?
Are you going to succeed as an employee?
So forth.
Once we think about this pipeline and
how it lives both in the online and the offline world,
there are a lot of questions that people
have began to ask
including questions over here on the right hand side.
Is the right outcome actually being predicted?
When I try introducing an algorithm into
some complex situation and say,
"I'm here to make a prediction."
Are you really making a prediction that's relevant to
the overall decision that the site is trying to optimize?
Similarly, lots of questions
get asked about this mapping.
Are we recording the right features about an individual?
Are those features reflecting
problems that we have even in the construction phase?
And finally, related to these first few points,
this broad question of,
is the algorithm making fair decisions?
Are the algorithm decisions fair?
And this clearly a complex definitional question
there as to what we mean by fairness.
And so that's what I want to start from in this talk.
The question of what would it mean
for algorithm decisions to be fair?
And here are a slightly more specific question,
what would it mean for algorithmic prediction to be fair?
Particularly, interested here in
this active prediction and
assigning an estimate of a probability.
Now, I've shown you some examples,
online content, employment education,
all of these have this kind of thing.
We could run through many other settings
where some sort of hybrid of a computer and
a human decision maker are making predictions
in granting loans and making medical diagnoses.
Wide range of areas where
this template actually fits quite well.
I want to talk about
the domain that Sendhil and I have been
focusing on for the past several years
which is Criminal Justice.
And we have been working together with Jens Ludwig,
Jure Leskovec and Himabindu Lakkaraju on
developing prediction algorithms in
this domain and trying
to look for places where human judges might
be making errors and making sub-optimal decisions.
And around the time we were doing that,
this extremely widely circulated article
by ProPublica came out in summer of 2016,
gathered a huge amount of attention.
And it was focused on a risk tool that was
actually being used in parts
of the U.S. criminal justice system.
This tool called COMPAS.
And, so, what was COMPAS doing?
COMPAS at a very high level
was taking features about
individual defendants and trying
to assign a level of risk.
A risk that they would re-offend
or perhaps within our powers of measurement,
at least the risk that they would be re-arrested.
Okay. And so, it was doing
this sort of a prediction activity.
And there were some appeared problems with COMPAS.
And so, ProPublica did this investigation.
It was actually a very nice example of
data journalism where the data
they used to evaluate COMPAS.
The code they used alteration, they put all of that
and GitHubs so that people could
replicate what they were doing and they arrived at
some relatively striking findings which they reported
in 36 point front in their article.
They identified some form
of bias in the decisions that was made.
Now, what was the bias that they identified?
Here, it is sort of summarized in
two bullet points in stylized form.
And for those who can't quite read about the site,
I'll read it out for you.
So, this is a signing level of risk to each defendants.
But each defendant then goes out in
the world and either commits,
either re-offense or not,
which again relates with our powers.
The measure means gets re-arrested or not.
And so, the first finding was
that African-American defendants who
didn't subsequently re-offend had
higher average scores than white defendants,
who didn't subsequently re-offend.
In the first of all point was concerning
because what we're talking about in
this first bullet is a whole bunch of people,
none of whom did anything wrong in the future.
And yet, the average score
assigned to the African-American defendants in
that category was higher than what was
like to the white defendants.
Conversely, the same thing happens in
the opposite direction with people who did re-offend.
White defendants who subsequently re-offended had
lower average scores than African-American defendants,
who subsequently re-offended.
Okay. So, both of these seem like some source of concern.
And especially, the first bullet is
a good one to focus on, right?
People who didn't do
anything wrong in the future
and yet we're getting these different scores.
And usually of the scores assigned to somebody as,
it incurs a big cost on, right?
If you get a high score,
that's now something which has consequences
in how you get treated by the U.S. criminal justices.
Okay. Yeah. Question?
>> [inaudible] How do they compute the top score?
>> Oh, yeah. Right. So, this is something that we
dealt with a lot in the work that we've been doing,
where if I release
someone I find out what
happened if I don't release someone.
In these particular cases,
these were four offenses that were going to involve
relatively short term detention and so they were
using what happened after they
were released either immediately or eventually.
Actually, many issues, one of which is that one,
make this kind of analysis much more complicated.
And in the kind of activity that followed this report,
a lot of the methodology here was question,
was refined, and so forth.
Fundamentally, this category of objections was robust.
In the sense that, for a lot of
different ways of looking at this,
this seemed to be happening.
Yeah. Are there were questions about the. Sir?
>> Yeah. So, assuming the [inaudible] significant.
>> Assuming.
>> So, you're saying the average score,
I guess, is higher but [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
There was a relatively non-trivial difference here.
>> Okay.
>> So.
>> How do you know that, you know that
this is just because of
[inaudible] other factors that would be harder that to.
>> The question will be to
get into like why is this happening right?
We should be asking why is this happening?
But, we should remember that in the end,
if we think about this as
an activity in the world, right?
So, when we say it may have to do with the features,
it may have to do with
covariance and the feature and so forth,
that's fine, but that was our decision
to impose that structure in the situation.
What's actually happening in the world is
defendants walk into a courtroom,
they're assigned scores,
where high scores impose
a relatively high cost
on them and how they're treated in the future.
Scores get signed to them, they leave
the courtroom and none of them do anything wrong, right?
So in the world what's
happening is people past through the system,
don't really run in the future, yet we've picked
this category of people and
we've assigned them higher scores.
We could discuss why we're doing that,
but fundamentally that end-to
end-process seems like it has something wrong with it.
And now that was fundamentally their argument.
So, in the analysis that followed,
the first thing that
happened was people said, "All right well,
if this is an issue with the COMPAS risk tool,
maybe something- if you
want to understand what's happening,
can we understand at least what COMPAS
was optimized to do?"
And there actually was an interesting point here,
and this was made both
by people who were involved with the creation of
the COMPAS tool and also by
a collection of researchers in crime policy who
pointed out that there is another definition
that we should be thinking about when
we evaluate risk tools,
which is not the ones that ProPublica's suggested,
but rather this notion of calibration.
And in fact COMPAS's scores
were well calibrated for each group separately.
So, what do I mean by calibration?
So we could think of a risk tool as
just criticizing the space of risks and so
it's assigning defendants to these bins.
This is the 0.1 risk bin,
0.2, 0.4 and so forth.
Point one means you only have
10 percent chance of re-offending.
And again, whenever I say
re-offending I mean re-offending in
the context where you've been arrested
by the criminal justice system
which is all that we're measuring.
And so if it's well
calibrated to be the case that when I look into this bin,
one-tenth of all the people there did reoffend.
Because one-tenth should mean one-tenth.
And when I look into the 0.2 bin a 0.2
fraction of the people should
reoffend because that's what point two means.
And indeed that is
the property that the COMPAS scores had.
And they had it separately for each group.
It had it for the African-American defendants,
it had for the white defendants, right?
So, their point was when we assign
an African-American defendant a score
of 0.2, it means 0.2.
If you were to go and look later 20 percent
of those people re-offended.
Point two meant 0.2. If you look
at the white defense who got assigned a score of 0.2,
0.2 meant 0.2, right?
So this in their argument
there's not much more we can do beyond that promise.
We promised that the numbers would mean what
they said, they do mean what they said.
And adding race into
this does not differentiate between that
because it's calibrated separately within
each group, score of S means the same.
Now, you could ask well,
is calibration important I mean it sounds good.
Is there some societal benefit to having calibration.
For one thing, it feels somehow
important that your tools output
means what it claims to mean,
but it's also the case that
uncalibrated rules can induce bad behavior.
So let me tell a sort
of fictitious pedagogical story about
a world in which some entity uses
an uncalibrated tool and let's
think about what what might happen, right?
So I suppose in my fictitious world hospitals run
a tool to predict
very accurately how good a doctor you're going to be.
And they hire candidates by stratifying them into
bins and only hiring
the candidate with the very highest score s*.
But suppose the rule is not calibrated across groups.
In particular that would mean something
like female doctors with the score s* are
actually more likely to be good doctors than
male doctors with the same score s*, right?
S* does not mean s* for the two groups.
In fact the probably is higher
for the female doctor who gets s*.
That would be what it would mean for
the rule to be uncalibrated.
Then the point is as
a patient it would now actually become
rational for you to choose
your doctor at least in part based on their gender.
Gender has now actually become an informative
feature in your selection of doctors.
The tool actually is encouraging to do it.
It says in fact,
one group actually has a higher probability of being
a good doctor than the other.
So even if you're sort of
imposed self-discipline and choose to
ignore this failure calibration,
the downstream people in society may not be doing that.
So this is one of the styles of
arguments why you might want calibration across groups.
Okay. So, calibration is important.
On the other hand ProPublica's objections still
remained, right?
They still seem to the problem. So, the question was,
could we achieve all of these desired properties?
We now have multiple properties all of
which seem to connote fairness.
And at this point an elaborate argument
ensued and Sendhil and Minish and I sort
of watching this felt
like if we can at least write down the definitions that
people are arguing about which is so far
gone sort of only partially
specified maybe we can actually look at
the situation try to figure
out what the argument is actually about.
And so, this next few slides is
really about something which
mathematically ends up not being that hard.
The challenge is to figure out what
is the sort of definitional content of this argument.
So, here's what we're
talking about in terms of our model.
So the basic model for assigning
risk scores is probability estimates
is that I have individuals.
They each have two things that are salient,
they are either positive or negative, right?
They will reoffend or they won't reoffend,
they'll be a good employee or
they won't be a good employee.
There's some kind of notion of
the positive class, the negative class.
And they also belong to one of two groups, right?
Two groups where I'm interested in the imbalance
between them or lack thereof. Groups A or B.
The in focus maps the feature vector and then
my risk score maps them to one of a set of bins,
bin B has a score of Visa B which
is sort of the probability estimate to do that.
Okay. So and that's
fundamentally what a risk tool is doing.
What are the properties that I
would like from my risk tool.
Well, here are the
three that we've been talking about so far.
Calibration within groups means
that for each group A and B,
A visa B fraction of people in bin b
are in fact positive.
Then I have these
issues with the ProPublica raised, right?
These definitions which really hadn't
necessarily been as much on the radar in
the discussion about these
things until the report came out.
So, on the positive classroom
I asked for what I might call balance.
That the average score of the positive members in
group A should equal
the average score the positive members in group B.
And similarly I might want
balance for the negative class.
So the average score of
negative members in group A should
be equal the average score of
negative members in group B.
Three properties that I might want.
All of which seemed to connote some kind
of fairness in the system.
Okay. So, let's ask
how might we try to achieve all of these properties?
Well, let's first try out
some simple cases where we can achieve them.
The first case would be, if I have
perfect prediction which is a really extreme case,
then I can actually achieve all three properties, right?
If the features in my data are actually enough that I can
deterministically tell if someone's in
the positive class or the negative class,
then when I'm deterministically sure as
some of the positive class I give them a score of one,
when I'm deterministically sure there
are in the negative class I give them
a score of zero and in fact
I'll achieve all three properties you can check that.
>> Can you go back to the slide.
>> Yeah.
>> So how do you get balance to a positive class?
>> So, the average score of
positive members and the average score
of it all [inaudible] equals one in that case.
As in if all members of the positive class.
>> Given your positive the average score was-
>> Exactly. Given the positive.
Yeah. So in the case of
ProPublica prediction which we don't
expect to have, we could achieve this.
A second case maybe a more plausible case where we
could also achieve this would be equal base rates.
Suppose the two groups have the same fraction of
positive instances some number p. Well,
then at least there always is
a risk score that satisfies all the properties.
I simply assign a probability P to everybody.
I create one bin, I put everybody into it and they
get a score of p. Now,
clearly that satisfies balance because
everybody's average is p. And also satisfies
calibration because there's a single bin
and a p fraction people in their given.
So in that case, I could at least get a risk score.
Maybe in the case of equal base rates
if there's some structure in the problem I
could create another solution
that's a more non-trivial risk or with multiple bins.
But the very least I can satisfy all three properties.
Okay. So we now have sort of two endpoints here.
And so we thought about, okay how can we sort of
work our way in from these two extremes?
And the sort of
first main thing I want to
talk about is that you can't actually.
So, in any instance of
risk score assignment where all three properties can be
achieved you have to either have
perfect prediction or equal base rates.
These are the only two situations in which
you can actually have all three of those properties.
So I want to walk through why
that's true, because as I said,
the proof's in the section of the talk are
actually quite easy in some sense
our challenge had been to sort of unravel what was being
talked about and try to find out what
the definitions were that people were arguing.
Once you do that it's
not that hard to see what's going on.
And in particular, I should
mention a couple of things about this, right?
The way we've defined things
it gets us to a point where this is not
a theorem it's about
computational power or inferential power,
it's really just about your inability to
assign numbers to entities
to equalize certain averages, right?
So, as a result it's not
really about the limitations of algorithms.
Any decision making procedure
that attempts to assign numbers
to people is going to
fail on one of these properties.Yeah.
>> So this score
is the previous score that you mentioned that.
>> No so actually.
>> Have equal base rates?
>> Yeah. If you have equal base rates
it's going to depend on the instance.
So in fact a slide that I don't have here if
I give you an instance of this problem
with equal base rates and I ask,
does there exist a non-trivial score that's
actually np hard to figure out if there is or isn't.
Because there's sort of a knapsack
like activity that you are subsets on
like activity you would have to do and
get a non-trivial one.
So yes. So it's going to be instance dependent.
Prediction for one positive,
one negative in both groups,
can you sacrifice scores on
those people who balance it out?
Suppose we know that somebody is positive,
you can assign an any positive score above threshold.
Somebody is negative for any
negative score below threshold.
>> I see. Sorry, are you proposing
a change in the requirements
or are you proposing a method to?
>> Yeah, method of solution.
If you know one through than the one through negative.
>> If I have equal base
rates that's how I could start to try
finding a non-trivial assignment of risk scores.
I could sort of locally search for it and that's right.
If I have unequal base rates as I'm going to
argue, we're not actually going do it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, this was
interesting to us because
it somehow said that the crux of this debate was that,
you really can't achieve everything
that people want to
unless you're in one of
these situations and fundamentally saying,
once you have unequal base rates,
there's a problem, right?
There's a problem if
these two groups have unequal base rates.
And sort of no amount of
clever authoring of definitions
is going to really make that go away.
It's going to show up somewhere.
So, we went back to talk to ProPublica half a year later,
because they generate a lot of activity.
And a number of groups actually
we're thinking about similar sorts of questions,
and so these all got summarized in
a kind of year-end wrap up that they wrote.
Coming back to this question and saying that in
fact the situation was sort of,
it wasn't just about the data that they had collected.
There were certain mathematical issues going on.
Some of the other work that
got summarized in all of this.
There was some nice work concurrent with
ours by Alexandra Chouldechova at Carnegie Mellon,
looking at a similar setting except
where the algorithm is supposed
to output a hard decision,
not a probably estimate but a yes- no decision and now I
ask about false positive rates and false negative rates.
And there's a similar negative result about
equalizing certain sets of
false positives and false negative rates.
Similar results by a group
at Stanford Corbett Davies et al.
Some nice work of Moritz Hardt,
Eric Price, and Nathan Srebro,
who looked at the case in which
you take away calibration,
which, again, comes at some cost.
But then, we could
look at a constrained optimization problem,
how could I be as accurate as possible if I want
to equalize false positive rates,
equal false negative rates.
Or, in our terms impose balance for
the positive-negative classes and then
try to be as accurate as possible,
which will necessarily typically sacrifice calibration.
We also in a paper nips this past year
looked at some other versions of this where for example,
if I want to retain calibration,
I can basically equalize any kind of
one dimensional combination of
the balance for the positive-negative classes
but not both simultaneously.
Let me give you a quick sketch of, yeah, question.
>> In the change of requirements,
is there any limits on the bias
that we can work towards to so I can better know?.
>> Yeah, right. It's a good question.
So can we get some approximate version.
So, if I write down a notion of
approximation in a really sort of simple way,
I say, I would like
approximate calibration to with an Epsilon.
I'd like equalizing averages within Epsilon and I'd like
equalizing balance cost negative within Epsilon, then no.
In fact, basically it says you have to have
either approximately perfect prediction or
approximately equal base rates and
that's the only situation.
Other forms of approximation I think are sort of in
these lower bullets here where it's basically saying,
we may have to just wholesale
give up on one of these conditions.
And I think part of the message here is going to be that,
which condition you want to give up.
I'm going to argue as a sort of
non-technical point is going to be domain dependent.
And there are certain extremes, right.?
There are situations where the societal cost of
having unequal averages for
people who committed no crime for example,
we view as very high and that's what we want to focus on,
and if we loosen calibration, so be it.
There are other domains where giving
up on calibration for the sake of
balance seems to make very little sense.
So, for example, take medical,
take a sort of hypothetical medical diagnosis setting,
where I have a rare disease,
do some test for it,
which returns with some probability.
And the disease for
some genuine genetic or physiological reason
say is more common in men than women.
Okay. So, the base rates are unequal.
So now the risk score
for that disease fits in our framework.
You take the features of the person,
you output or probably that they
have the disease based on what you measured.
It could be high, it could be low based
on various tests that you ran.
But because the base rates are unequal and you
have imperfect prediction and
you're going to have some disparity
across men and women, right?
There it feels like the fact that the average for
the positive class negative class are unequal is somehow
a feature of just the nature of the disease, right?
It's not necessary reflecting something wrong in
society relative just a fact about this disease.
Whereas having a rule that's uncalibrated,
in that case, it would be strange.
It would mean you would go
to the doctor, and the doctor would say,
"Well we looked at some features
and this thing reports a 20 percent chance,
but because you're male, we have to adjust
that because it's an uncalibrated."
It's somehow wouldn't necessarily
make sense to go to calibration in that case.
So, I think which one you want to give
up is going to be domain-dependent
and it's going depend on what we view as
the relative cost of these different forms of unfairness.
Let me just mention two slides
about the proof just to kind of emphasize that
it's really not very
complicated at all, once we have these definitions.
If you want to watch for something in the proof,
it might be the following,
which is somewhere in the proof of course.
We're going to have to mention perfect
prediction equal base rates.
Because the theorem is not, you can never do this.
The theorem is you can only do it in these two cases.
And these two cases are kind of a combination
of like a zero dimensional case,
where things are pinned down to constants and
kind of a one dimensional case
where two things are equalized.
So, somewhere in the proof, short though it is,
it's going to have to be kind of
a zero dimensional thing glued to
a one dimensional thing that's going to somehow say
these are the two cases. So watch for that.
Okay. So we have these groups,
let's say N sub t is the number of people in group t,
K sub t is the expected number of people in
the positive class in group t. And I'm sort
of speaking informally and all of
this takes a little
more to write this down more carefully.
So the calibration condition, if you think about it says,
it has been one out of 10 people commit a crime.
And we have 10 people assigned the score of point one,
which is a total score of one.
Similarly here we've assigned 10 copies of point two,
which is a total score of two
and two people commit a crime.
Fundamentally, the calibration is saying,
the total score handed out in the bin is equal to
the expected number of people in that bin
who actually are in the positive class.
And something overall bins that basically says,
the total score handed out to all of
group t is going to be
the expected number of positive people
in group t. All right.
So let's remember that. Okay. Let's say
we have the average score of a person in
the negative class, we'll call that X.
The average score of a person in
the positive class we'll call that Y.
The key is because we've equalized the averages that's
independent of the group we're talking
about. That's crucial.
So here's a way to write the total score in
group t. nt minus kt people were in the negative class,
they get a score of X on average.
Kt are in the positive class,
they get score of Y on average.
On the other hand,
we know that the total score handed out as
Kt by calibration. So I get this equation.
So now I have two equations,
one for the first group, one for the second group.
Each of these equations specifies
some line relating X and Y.
Here are those two lines.
And now the question is,
when can those be simultaneously satisfied?
Well, one is at the point
zero one, which is perfect prediction.
And the other is if these two slopes happen to be equal,
in which case, they coincide
all the way along these lines,
which is the case of equal base rates.
So, fundamentally that's what's going on.
And we have to be a little
more careful in how we write everything down.
But that's basically.
Okay. So we looked at this and we thought they sort of,
some interesting thing is going on here.
And we began thinking about the ways in which probably
estimates are being used more broadly.
So we thought about that this
is sort of one first look at
this activity of taking
people and making probabilistic estimates about them,
and then making decisions based on that.
But many of those situations
involve more than just one individual, right.
What is interesting here is that,
we're auditing the rule.
We're evaluating it by looking at averages over groups,
but the rule, itself, is being applied
one individual at a time.
Fundamentally, the activity is
the risk score takes in a single individual and
outputs a single number and there are
many cases when we assign
problems to get estimates about people.
What we're really doing is evaluating a group, right?
We're applying a function to a set not to
an individual. What do I mean by that?
Well, we all sort
of encounter that on a regular basis, right?
So just to take a sort of representative example.
A couple of years ago there was this headline
during college admissions season
in the Cornell Chronicle,
which is our local on-campus news,
which says, "The admitted class of 2019 is the
most diverse in Cornell history."
That's a statement about a group,
saying about the admitted class, right?
No one individual is the most diverse in Cornell history.
It's really what happens when you bring together a group
of people and evaluate their diversity as a set.
I'm evaluating sets.
And this was really a point
brought to the fore by the work of Scott Page,
this social scientist at the University of Michigan,
who does very interesting work.
And has written for a number of years on the issue of
diversity as a sort of emergent property of
groups and the performance benefits of diversity.
And college admissions is one of
the examples which he thinks about.
But of course, there are a number of other
settings when we think about this.
Often missing in the discussion of
assignments or loans for example, right.
We think people making loan decisions is that in
the end you have to evaluate loans collectively.
Right. You're really valuing the portfolio of
loans not anyone individually.
Similarly, a bunch of
work starting with work of Scott page,
and then some stuff is going to
work that might Rod and I do,
which I'll mention toward the end.
Looking at for example, if I wanted to select
a team to maximize team performance,
I should be evaluating the team not necessarily
the individuals on the team.
So you end up with
this challenge in which we're trying to evaluate
a group by making probabilistic estimates about
the individuals and what's going to happen there.
So, it means Rod and I are having thought about
this assignment of risk score has began
thinking about this in the context of group selection,
and asked what are some of the issues that come up there?
And we came across this interesting thing which really
hadn't been sort of analyzed mathematically.
We've had some interesting properties.
So again to kind of recap what
we kind of a generic situation that we're thinking about.
We have a large pool of applicants,
we'd like to choose a short list of K.
So maybe that's our entering college class.
Maybe, I guess the canonical example
might be these are the job applicants and we're going to
select K to kind of
interview or sort of look extra hard at.
Okay. And we'd like
this group of K to be as good as possible.
Now the concern is that there's bias in the system,
either explicit a bias or maybe implicit bias such that,
maybe group X is
a group where we're concerned there's
bias against group X.
So we have X candidates and
Y candidates depending on their group membership.
And we're worried that whoever is making
the decision has this bias against members of group X,
where they sort of down weight them.
And either it's implicit bias
that they can't control or
they somehow choose not to control.
What do we do in those kinds of situations?
So there's an intervention that's become increasingly
popular in the business world,
in academia, something called the Rooney Rule.
And actually a number of you
have no doubt encountered it,
even if you haven't called it the Rooney Rule.
And that's saying, when you're hiring for a job for say,
a faculty position, an executive position, what have you.
You commit that on your short list of interviewees,
you promised that at least one of
the people on that list will be from group X.
>> This is the group
you're concerned that you're discriminating against,
so if you see a pool
of interviewees and all of them are from
group Y then whoever is higher up
in management says, "I reject that list.
You need to interview at least one person from group X."
Why is this called the Rooney Rule?
Because, the first really public pronouncement,
and sort of commitment,
so this actually came in 2002
by the owners of the teams in National Football League.
The Rooney Rule is named after Dan Rooney,
who at the time was the owner of the Pittsburgh Steelers.
Where looking at the incredibly low representation
of minority head coaches in the NFL,
which was of course especially striking given
the high representation among the players for example.
They want to figure out how can we increase
the fraction of head coaches in the NFL
who are from minority groups?
And so this was the rule that they set out.
And it's becoming increasingly popular a little
because it somehow aims at
the sort of middle layer between no intervention,
just everyone should try harder,
which felt like it somehow wasn't getting anywhere.
And more heavyweight interventions,
where for example you commit to actually hiring
a certain number which then is subject to
sort of significantly more complex territory
in discrimination law.
Right, so this is somehow something in the middle,
you're committing to look extra hard
at members of this group.
So this has become
again sort of increasing in popular intervention.
It was invoked by Barack Obama in 2015,
where he exhorted the tech industry to
use this in executive hiring when a commission
chaired by Eric Holder
reviewed the situation of Uber in 2017,
they made this among their recommendations
for executive hiring as well.
Okay, that's the Rooney Rule.
It had an effect actually,
just to kind of show a little data here.
This interesting paper by
Cynthia DuBois from two years ago,
looked at the moment the rule was introduced,
just after the 2002 season.
What happened to the representation
of minority groups among NFL head coaches?
And comparing it to a bunch of reference
populations where the rule
was not applied: offensive and defensive coordinators,
head coaches of NCAA college teams,
none of whom were actually using the Rooney Rule.
Again there's a lot of noise,
right, this is incredibly small numbers.
But the two have been sort of roughly on top of
each other and diverged sharply right on the field.
So there's evidence that
this was actually having an effect over time.
But we actually want to ask in the spirit of this work of
Scott Page who wants to think about
the performance benefits of diversity, right.
Independent of any of the
other reasons that we might do it.
Could it simply be a performance gain from
imposing the Rooney Rule on people? Okay? Yes.
>> Do the interviewers and interviewees
know that this rule is being
applied, when it is being applied?
>> In the case of the NFL, yes.
It's situation dependent,
so the original articulation of it was,
yes, there was an extremely public commitment
to this and so everyone knew it was being applied.
You can imagine situations where the firm
decides to use it but not to announce it,
and then you might have a different situation.
>> Is there anything that happened that
led to the dropping in the end?
>> There's been some discussion that,
there's sort of two theories about this.
One is, it's small numbers, this is noise.
The other could be
there's concern that the rule is beginning to
break down in that increasingly people have
a sense of who they want as their head coach,
and so you end up committing to
somehow a set of interviews
that don't actually have much power
because you've sort of already decided.
So there's concern that people have learned how to engage
in the rules sort of in form,
but not in spirit.
It's unclear though, yes.
Okay, so pure performance benefits from this.
Why might there be a pure performance benefit
from using the Rooney Rule in
this case with probabilistic prediction?
And again, for performance
I need some kind of an objective function.
I'm going to start with
the objective function that just says,
"I would like to maximize the sum of
the qualities of the K people that I interview."
There's a choice there because you could say, "Well,
I'm just trying to hire one person,
I should just maximize that person."
But there's lots of evidence.
One of the real motivations
behind introducing rules like this,
is that all K people you interview
benefit from the exposure of being interviewed.
For example, the people involved in interviewing them
all go off to go work for
different firms or different teams,
or whatever over time, and
they're going to be involved in recruiting,
and they're going to have people who come to
mind who are in their working memory,
and if you were interviewed
earlier there's a benefit to you.
So I'll start with something where we're looking
at some of the qualities of all k-people you interviewed,
in that all of them are somehow,
relevant to the situation.
Here's a model where I'm going to try to
suggest that there might be
a performance benefit in
cases where there's biased evaluation.
The model is going to have
the following three ingredients.
First, I have a pool of job applicants.
Each one has some potential for future performance.
This can be a stylized model
as with our previous set of slides,
where I'm going to try to,
what are sort of the minimal set of
ingredients I'm going to need to be
able to ask this question, okay?
I'm going to need some kind of distribution
over future performance, right.
Hiring involves some uncertainty about like,
who is it who's actually, who I'm going be getting?
Most of the domains where the Rooney Rule is being
applied are what you might call Creative professions,
where there's a kind of unbounded domain
of how good they can do in the future.
Again, think about hiring
researchers to take some crust numerical measure.
Maybe we're trying to estimate at
the end of their career what will
be their Google Scholar citation count, right?
A terrible thing to focus on as a unit, eventual quality,
but sort of it conveys the idea, right?
If we're using this rule to figure
out who in our portfolio of recording artist we hired,
we might be looking at song downloads,
we might be looking at
revenue generated if we're trying to
hire sales people and so forth.
All of these have the property that they
tend to come from heavy-tailed distribution, right?
There is an enormous amount of empirical work
now and citation statistics,
that say your lifetime
future citations is as heavy-tailed distribution,
in which outliers are quite common.
So, imagine that your probability that
your lifetime output exceeds T,
is sum of T is the -1 + Delta.
Okay? I think I actually have parenthesized that wrong,
it should be the minus is outside the parentheses.
Okay. So, good.
So this is a domain in which this notion that
we're trying to hire superstars,
is somehow formalized by the fact that we
have this very heavy-tailed distribution,
you see really big numbers, that's important.
Okay, second we have candidates
applying from groups X and Y,
and there are different compositions, right?
If I have n candidates from group Y,
the group's experiences no bias.
I'll imagine I have Alpha times n, from group X.
Okay. So, because the second thing
that you have to worry about when you think about
applying the Rooney Rule is how prevalent
is this group in the applicant population?
If there are only one percent
of the applicant population,
you pay a very large cost by
committing one of your slots to them.
If they're at parity,
if Alpha equals one,
then in fact the bias
might be hurting a huge number of people.
Okay, I'm going to make the assumption because
it's sort of the most basic assumption you make that,
all are drawn from the same power law distribution Z.
We clearly look at the case where the two groups,
maybe because of future bias they're going to experience
different distributions going forward in the future,
but we'll start with this one.
And finally, so far there's no bias in this situation,
so far groups X and Y are indistinguishable.
Let's add bias.
So there's some evidence
from psychometric work on implicit bias,
that for some of
these estimates when you actually do experiments,
have people look at CVs,
make estimates relative to for example,
true lifetime citation counts,
that there's often something that looks
like a multiplicative offset in these estimates.
So imagine there's a bias parameter beta,
Beta for bias, greater than one.
So the selection committee picking people,
believes that the potential of the IFX candidate,
which is XI, they evaluate as XI divided by data.
So their estimate is knocked down by data.
That may again be because of implicit bias,
they can't control may be because of explicit
of bias that they are actually down rating it,
but one way or another that's what's happening.
And then they have to pick a shortlist of K. So,
fundamentally it's this pipeline.
Applicants are drawn from this,
some are X candidates, some are Y candidates.
They all get sorted,
but the X candidates all get scaled
down by this factor one over Beta,
before they get merged sorted in.
And then we pick the top K. So for example,
here if K were three,
the Rooney rule wouldn't be necessary because
one of your three on
your shortlist already is an X candidate.
But if K were too, this list would be unacceptable,
you would need to pick this third candidate.
And so here's the question that we ask,
"Why might the Rooney Rule be helping?"
After all I'm restricting your actions.
Previously, you had an unconstrained optimization problem
where you could pick any K you wanted.
Now, I'm making you only pick list of K,
where one of them is from group X.
Why might that possibly be helping.?
Well, because of course, the point is
that the people of group X have been shifted down.
And so when I'm only allowed to pick the top two,
and I swap in this person for that person,
it might be a win, because this person may have
been better and we just divide them by Beta.
Or maybe a loss, because maybe the reason
this blue bar is
above the red one is because they really were better.
That's somehow the issue, right?
That what it's doing is
putting people into the shortlist,
who may have been knocked out because of bias,
but may have been knocked out
just because they were ranked lower.
That's what we have to think about.
So there may be a performance gain,
there maybe a performance hit,
and we have to figure which one we're in.
Okay. So, that's the question we're asking.
I should mention that actually this
is sort of a natural example of
something from economic theory known as Delegation.
Delegation is a- which actually
dates back to one of
the first articulations of the theory.
Delegation was actually in the Nobel laureate
Ben Tolstrooms PhD.
thesis from the 1970s.
Delegation is a very constrained form of
the broader topic of Mechanism Design.
And Mechanism Designing principle
makes up a set of rules for
a game that agents play and they're
trying to create a certain behavior.
But Mechanism Design tends to
involve things like monetary transfers,
where you reward people differently for what they do.
Delegation says we have
a situation where all the principal
can do is refuse to accept certain solutions.
They send the agent out to search for
a solution, but they say,
"I'll reject solutions with the following predicate,
and so you have to find something that passes my filter."
And by constraining the agent's action
they're actually trying to
actually create a better solution by recon and price.
So you think of the Rooney Rule as
a very simple form of delegation,
where somewhere higher up the chain, someone says,
"I won't accept lists that are only Y candidates."
And finally, the utility is the K finals job.
Okay, so the main result
in the work that initially I've been doing,
is a characterization for every short-list size
K of the choices of Alpha,
the pool composition, what fraction are X candidates?
Beta level of bias and Delta,
the power law exponent,
abundance of outliers for which
the Rooney Rule produces actually
a positive change in expectation,
rather than a negative change in expectation. And, yes.
>> So, going back to the slide,
will you deduce the sum of?
>> Yes.
>> Doesn [inaudible] choosing one.
>> Yes. That was what I said earlier where,
the other natural thing would be
the utility of some other max.
I'll come back to max time permitting.
I mean we may run out of time with that.
My argument for this sum is
that in many of these situations,
where the Rooney Rule is being applied,
in some sense,
everyone's benefiting from being interviewed, again,
because of this notion that any interviews are
generating more interviews both
now and temporally going forward.
Everyone may not be benefiting equally.
The one that you choose is- Some of your,
sort of was actually
part of the original motivation, right?
Part of it is always for interviewing
minority head coaching candidate.
Was it that was actually leading to sort
of them getting more interviews in the future,
than being sort of
working set of people trying to recruit.
Some is some kind of a price mission but
I'll come back and think about Max also.
It's also the case that the Rooney Rule
is increasingly being used,
for example for things like I'm
giving out a prize to five people.
I want one to be from a group
where I'm treating them symmetrically.
I'm creating an advisory committee of eight people.
I want one to meet them.
They are the use of some of this, maybe more-
>> In general, you'd want me [inaudible]
>> You might to tell me
where- That will be natural to look at Ellison.
You can get some characterization.
I want to talk about a couple of things
that we learned from a thing about this characterization.
In particular, I wanted to [inaudible]
the technical details here to zero in on.
Two things purely mathematically about the nature of
bias that I feel like I didn't
understand before we did this,
that I now understand better.
I want to sort of pull those two out and talk about them.
First of all, here is the actual form of
the statement for every constant K [inaudible] too.
There's some exclusive function Phi sub
K. It improves utility if and only if,
some property that is greater than one.
Implicitly, this basically says,
if I fix- Let's think about fixing Alpha and Delta,
which are two things that are actually measurable.
I can measure the fraction of people who
are X candidates and I can
from past history measure the distribution of
lifetime future performance and
get some Power of law exponent Delta.
Alpha and Delta I know, Beta is arguably the elusive one.
You can think of this as
defining implicit function that
says for any Alpha and Delta,
what is the Beta at which I
start using the Rooney Rule, right?
At some level of bias I say,
now the level of bias is so high I need to start using
it and it's going to be functional from Delta.
We can believe that Beta is implicitly a function.
The actual functional forms of
these even for Kagle is too rather complicated.
I'm not really going to talk about the functional forms.
It was striking to us it's so
complicated because I've told you the whole model.
There is not a lot going on in the model and so the fact
this is the exact condition is a little surprising.
If you plot this implicit function
of Beta as I was talking about,
you get this, which
in some way is also sort of complicated.
Let me sort of walk you through this because
embedded in this is sort of two things.
As I said, that I felt like I learned about bias
from staring at this again, Alpha goes this way.
This is shrinking Alpha. Delta goes this way.
This is a string. As we go this way,
there were fewer and fewer X candidates.
It makes sense that this thing
is peeling upwards because you
need more and more bias
to be willing to use the Rooney Rule.
If only 20 percent of your pool is
X candidates- If
only five percent of pool is X candidates.
You would need a lot of bias to be willing to use it.
Maybe no amount of bias would be
sufficient. Let's come back to that question.
Delta is a little more complicated right?
Delta goes to zero.
I get more and more heavy tailed distributions
where the outliers get more and more extreme.
That tends to have the property,
that when somebody wins,
they may be winning by a huge amount.
You are very hesitant to swap them out for somebody else.
This sort of peels upward as Delta
gets small although not
completely because there is this totally weird region
which I want to try to explain in this talk,
where it's actually non-monotone,
where as you very Delta, you go from wanting,
from not wanting to use the rule to wanting to use it
to not wanting to use it again.
Complicate things we have here.
Let's first talk about this cliff though
because it's actually climbing to infinity.
This cliffs climbing into infinity is
sort of an interesting climb which says,
'This is the frontier at which you wouldn't
even want to use the Rooney Rule in
the case of infinite bias.'
As you mentioned, this whole surface is for K equals two.
Let me just discussion k equals two where it's already
[inaudible] What does that frontier look like, right?
What are the values of Alpha and Delta for which
the Rooney Rule does or doesn't improve
utility as the bias to infinity?
In other words, when do you reserve a slot for
an X candidate in case of infinite bias?
Now, these are interesting questions.
It says, suppose I'm giving out a prize to two people,
if I didn't constrain people's behavior,
they would always just give it to
the top two Y candidates.
Somehow when they go to give out awards,
Y candidates are the only names that come to mind.
I could constrain their behavior and say, 'No.
This award, we'll have one goes to an X candidate,
one goes to a Y candidate.'
I'm imposing that. Now, we'd
like to look back 20 years later
at the history of our award.
Look at everyone's Google Scholar citation counts maybe.
Add them up and say, 'In which world are we
going to be prouder of
the people who we gave the award to?
In a world where I was always just giving it to
two Y candidates or
the rule where I gave it to one X and one Y?'
It's a concrete question where you go and look at
where in which one do I
increase the sense of expectation.
Surprising facts, which in the end has
a explanation that makes
sense that no matter
how small the fraction of X candidates,
there is a small enough Power of law exponents so
that you should use the Rooney Rule.
In other words, even if only five percent
of your pool is from group X,
there are some small enough Power of law [inaudible]
Meaning a heavy enough tail on the distribution,
that even though only five percent
from a group X you should still- If I'm trying to
maximize utility reserve a slots
for someone from group X
and the other slots for the 95 percent
from group Y and
for a very concrete performance-based reason.
If you look back later and look at
how did these random variables actually turn out.
You will actually have done better
by reserving that slot.
I can sort of just sketch why that's true,
but then let me talk about why that's,
why that's so weird.
>> [inaudible]
>> Is this pie- Yes,
this pie is all about K equals to infinite bias,
which means you would never give it on your own.
Actually, [inaudible] let me talk about why it's so weird.
The argument is Z starts
the expected maximum of end draws from
power law of X plus one plus Delta.
This is the value of the top Y candidate,
because the top Y candidate comes from N people.
I'm drawing Power of law from each one and I'm
taking the best one.
My ability to rank within
each group is perfect and the simple model.
The problem is I just can't merge them.
I'm always putting Y candidate and X candidate.
Now, without the Rooney Rule,
the other candidate that we picked will certainly be
the second Y candidate because we have infinite bias.
If you do a little work with maximum of Power of law,
you get that the expected value that one is
Delta over one plus Delta times the Z star.
With the Rooney rule the other candidate
will be the top of the X candidates,
that's now Z star but scaled down,
by the fact there are only Alpha and, of them.
I get again doing a little work with Power of laws
that turns out to be Alpha to the 1
over 1 plus Delta times Z star.
I just compared these two, I canceled the Z star,
and I get it improves until if Alpha is greater
than Delta over 1 plus Delta to the one plus Delta.
Therefore, no matter how small Alpha is,
there's a sufficiently small Delta so Alpha is bigger.
Let me tell you why we wrote down
this thing and then we're like, this can't be right.
Think about what we're saying.
We have 100 percent,
100 applicants, hundred percent.
Say 20 percent are from group Y,
we're reserving a slot for them.
Take group X which
has 80 percent of people, split it in half.
Call them arbitrarily group A and group B.
Each has 40 percent of the people.
Now, the best person in group
A in expectation is better than the best person coming
from group X because there are
40 percent group A is only 20 percent
[inaudible] The best person from group
B is better than the best person group X.
Yet for some reason,
we're saying we're lumping together A and B.
Each of whom is someone better than
group X and we're treating group X separately.
How can that possibly be improving utility, right?
It seems wrong. Right?
You see the problem.
If I just chose to think
of group X as having these two groups
of 40 percent each. So what's going on?
So, what's going on is
that it's not the case that we're comparing
the best in A
and the best in X against the
best in A and the best in B.
In both cases, we're picking the best of A union B.
We're always getting the better of those two.
The other one we pick from
A union B is known to be the second best.
And when you have
a very very heavy-tail power low whereas
the person from group X because of the infinite bias,
we have no idea what the upper bound on them is.
And so the point is
when you have a very heavy-tailed power law,
the value of not having some conditional
upper bound on their performance is extremely powerful.
The fact that we know that the second white hand
that we picked is
not the top person already puts
this big constraint on how high they- I mean,
they're probably very good, but there's some upper bound.
The person in group X has no upper bound because
the bias may we never actually
directly compare them to someone genuinely.
Okay. So, that was the first thing I
learned about bias that I really
hadn't kind of understood.
But it really follows from
very simple assumptions and it's interesting
it's happening in this power law regime,
which is exactly the realm of Google Scholar counts,
view counts, download statistics where we
often apply things like the Rooney Rule.
Let me tell you the second thing I learned
about bias from this.
And that's the following,
so when we go to analyze this,
the basic object that we need to understand in
this analysis is what you might call an
Expectation Conditional on Comparison.
Okay, so that's the following thing.
The expectation of some random variable A,
given that A is greater
than constant C times some other random variable B.
Think of A and B as sort of the top
that is kind of a stylized thing,
abstracting from the analysis we're doing.
Think of A and B as the top candidates in the two groups.
C is some level of bias.
It says, "When we pick A,
it's because they have to be like bigger
than two times B."
And so we're interested in
how they are given that they're
bigger than two times the top candidate
in the other group,
because there's a bias to a factor of two, right.
So now we're back in the world of
finite bias where things are more complicated.
And so, syntactically it's
very compact thing to write down.
We felt like we understood it going in but it turns
out this kind of construction is a real mess, okay.
This idea that this person
is better than twice this other person,
both of whom were drawn from some distribution.
So, and this actually showed up in the empirical work.
For example, in the Cynthia DuBois's work
and the Rooney Rule,
where an actual question to ask is,
"What was the win-loss record
of minority head coaches before
the Rooney Rule and
what was the win-loss record afterwards?"
And you actually find again,
there are small numbers and now there's
really small numbers being involved.
But that somehow towards some approximation,
the win-loss record minority head coaches before
the Rooney Rule was actually slightly higher,
potentially because they were passing through
a stronger filter because of the bias.
Afterwards they became more equalized.
That's sort of intuitive,
higher filters should mean they're doing better.
But is that really what's going on?
So let's say I have
these independent random variables A and
B drawn from some distribution and I'm going
to find a function of C. I'm going to sweep over
the bias and ask what happens to this expectation.
In other words, how good is a candidate
A experiencing bias when they have to be
twice as good as the competition because of bias?
How could your expectancy be when they have to be
three times as good as the competition because of bias?
How about 10 times as good? Alright, that's what
happens as I sweep across C. So F
of C is how good I expect this candidate to be when
they're subjected to a level bias equal to a factor of C?
What can we say about this?
For example,
here's the most simple thing you'd like to ask,
is it monotone increasing in C?
If candidates have to pass through
increasing levels of bias,
does it follow an expectation their better?
Okay. I could tell this actually
as say a parable about hiring.
Let's say I had two research labs.
Both research labs prefer
hiring applied people to theory people.
So in the first research lab, every year,
there going to interview a
theory candidate and an applied candidate.
And the theory candidate has to be
at least twice as good as
the applied candidate to get hired.
The other lab drawing from the same distribution,
interviews a theory candidate and applied candidate.
But the theory candidate has be three times as good
or more compared to
the applied candidate in order to get hired.
Now we're going to look back
retrospectively 20 years later,
there will be fewer theory candidates at the second lab.
Will they be better on average
because they have to pass through the higher filter?
That's the monotonous question.
The answer is not necessarily.
For some distributions, they might actually be lower.
In that's sends to which I mean
this quality is a complete mess
that we don't really fully understand.
Here's a simple example to convince you of this.
Imagine this is the distribution.
So it's just a four-point distribution.
Actually there are
even simpler distributions where this happens.
So imagine, every year this
theory an applied candidate drawn
from distribution where the quantity is one,
five, nine or 13 uniformly random.
So the sample space is just this four by four grid,
there are 16 possible kinds
of recruiting years that you can have.
Right? This is the quality of the theory candidate,
this is the quality of the applied candidate.
What does the event A greater than 2B look like?
It says in these four kinds of years,
you end up hiring the theory candidate.
So, when the theory candidate is 13 and
the applied candidate is five
that's greater than two times five.
So you hire them. Similarly with these three.
And so your expected value was
the average quality over these which is 10.
We have to be three times as good,
then the slope shift downward
and you're only averaging over these three points.
Because you can only hire a theory candidate in
this world when the applied candidate was really,
really bad, which actually
puts less of a constraint with you.
So here actually you do the average, and it's nine.
So it says, if I would go and look at the research labs
20 years later in this very stylize scenario,
the research lab with the higher filter actually
has worse theory candidates people on average.
And in real life,
we would look at this and we'd say that could be for
any number of reasons which in real life would
probably be the dominant reasons for example a lab with
that high a filter is probably going to be unwelcoming to
theoreticians who won't want to go there
and so that's why you have weaker people there.
Or if they really have such a high filter,
they're probably also bad at evaluating
theoreticians as they pick the wrong people.
Maybe that's true also.
But neither of those has to be true.
This could happen for purely arithmetical reasons.
And that's somehow the point that this is
a very messy concept that we're dealing with.
And somehow this is at the heart of what we
have to do when we analyze the effect of
something like the Rooney Rule we're looking at
these expectations conditional on
comparison. Yeah, question.
>> Would this example hold
up if DNB coming from heavy tail distributions.
>> No. Actually for heavy tail distributions,
one thing we have to prove which
this suggests but not really
at least for power law distributions,
that function is monotone, which is somehow
the first step we need.
You could simply have a continuous density function
where it's not monotone.
I just put some bumps into it
and then I simulate something like this.
Actually we don't know it's a nice question.
Do all say uni monotone density functions
have the property that this thing is monotone increasing.
Someone may know the answer to that
we weren't able to figure it out.
>> So much ocf this analysis is
based with expectations which means
that you have to run
this process many many times to get the predicted effect.
Are there any kind of bounds that say well how many
times do you have to do this for
the specs to show with high probability or something?
>> Yeah that's an interesting question
because right it's based on outliers.
Now the outliers are relatively
frequent because it's power law.
But yeah, we have
some work on that sort of how fast this is converting.
I don't think there's
necessarily a crispy answer because it's going to
depend on the power blocks from them.
But the convergence here is
actually reasonably fast and it's also reasonably fast.
The other parameter in which you
might expect convergence is the number of
applicants in because all
of these are talks statements in that.
There are the convergence is relatively
quick and that the correction in terms that we're
dealing with are things like sort of one plus log n over
n. And so once and
gets to be in the hundreds, we're actually seeing this.
But yeah, it's double integration.
The expectations also say
expectations of power laws are part
of the challenge here when
we're looking at sort of average.
What's the total revenue?
Now of course, average is often what you care about.
If I'm hiring a team of sales people,
I care about the total revenue they generate,
I don't care about some other thing.
But it's an issue that we have to think about.
We could do a similar analysis saying,
what is the probability that the Rooney Rule
produces a positive change,
for example, rather than the expected change?
And then we get a somewhat simpler analysis
but still has some of the subtlety that we're seeing.
>> In the previous results where you were showing
what data you needed given the other parameters,
would you expect that if you had a little bit of noise to
the activation process there would be
about the same or does it change automatically?
>> Good question. Yes, so noise is
a nice and excrescence thing about.
The results we have right now say
for sufficiently small noise,
we get roughly the same results.
As the noise gets larger,
it's an interesting question whether
some non-trivial discrete transition happens
and what's going on and that's
not something that we fully understand.
In the infinite bias case, it's easy to
understand than the finite by bias case.
Yeah, isn't as clear.
Yeah, other questions? Let me
ask you kind of timekeeping questions,
I'll just wrap up in like two or three
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay,
in that case let me mention because you asked about Max.
Let me mention one more
thing less complicated than the reasoning about
the Rooney Rule which sort of goes even more directly to
Scott Page's work on diversity and then I will wrap up.
So fundamentally what we have been
talking about is an event where we
are choosing a short list of K people out of N people.
And there have really been
two things we have been talking about.
One is how do we evaluate individuals?
What score do we give them? And the other
is this question of how do we evaluate the set?
And so far the set we have just been summing.
But we might want to use
some other function to evaluate the set.
And what happens if we have some other function?
Right? So the point is if we are
just evaluating by the sum,
we should be doing what we have been doing.
We should compute everybody's expected value
and take the Max expected value.
But what if we are back in
this interviewing context where
really the reason we look to
K people is to pick the best one?
Should we actually, right, okay.
So imagine the following set
up. I look at the applicants.
I have to assign each one a numerical score.
I have to rank them by their score.
But am going to be judged on
the best person I pick
because maybe this is an interview context,
maybe I am a graduate
admissions committee that says what we really
want is for the most famous graduate
from our program to be as high as possible,
maybe we are choosing a team or we want,
we are going to be judged by the best
idea anyone the team has.
But for all those reasons Max
is kind of a natural thing to look at.
How do we do if we use the expectation as a score?
Is there some other score we should be using?
So let me show you one final example,
which I think also sort of teaches us something
about the problem with assigning scores.
So this is the sort of, you can call, contest objective.
If we can bring in the case shortlist we are going to
pick one after the interview.
They were scored by the Max.
So using the mean to sort
people has the following worrisome behavior.
Think of K as large here. Suppose I just had a pool.
I had two K applicants.
K of them produce high risk high reward.
They produce value K
minus one of them is probably one over
K. And K of them are really safe deterministic.
They produce value one with probably one.
So a test to evaluate
expectation chooses the second group of candidates
because they are expedition one
rather than one minus a tiny bit.
But as you might not be surprised to hear,
that would be a bad choice.
I should really do is,
I would truly do much better by picking
the K high risk high reward ones.
Why? Because each of them succeeds overwhelmingly in
this case with probably one over
K. So the chance that
at least one of them succeeds is a constant.
It's one minus one minus one over K to the K,
which is converging to one minus over E. So it
is constant probability I read the enormous reward.
And so an expectation and again we're
looking at the expected value I am doing much better.
So ranking by expected value is hurting me a lot
if my goal is to maximize
the expected quality of the Max.
Now Scott Page came across
similar examples and sort of ended up there and said,
this is the problem with using scores.
Right, when you score people and you rank them, you know,
he uses this as an indictment of SAT's and GRE's that
is reducing people to a uni-dimensional number,
and then when you sort and rank you might
actually miss the opportunity to do really well.
So, my thrill Ragav and I
looked at this and we
are intrigued by the following question.
Is the problem with scores or is
the problem with expected value as the score?
Just because the expected value is not working,
maybe there is some more clever uni-dimensional score
I could be using that would actually let me do well.
And the answer is that that's actually what is happening.
Here is a better test that you could
use that I am trying to pick the Max.
Rather than say let us look at
the mean performance of candidate I,
let us look at a different quantity.
Let us take candidate I,
and again we are in a stylized role
where we assume we know their distribution.
Let us imagine you drew
K times from
that person's distribution and then you took the Max.
So this is the best they would do if they
live their life K times over independently.
I mean, this is their upside potential.
Let me use that as the score.
It is again just the single number.
So I throw away all the information
about the distribution. I just keep that one number.
That is now my new GRE score or my new SAT score.
And I sort by that.
Then the theorem you can prove
is that there is some absolute constants,
C. So this is actually a factor
of C approximation to the optimum.
Right? If I could know everything about
the distribution and solve
the NP Hard Optimization Problem of picking
the K that we are going to have
the highest expected maximum,
I would not do better
than a factor of C in terms of what I
am doing by simply computing this
metric and sorting on it.
So there are a couple of things,
and this will be my final point here.
A couple of things that we learn from this, right?
One is that just because a vanilla test is not working,
like the expected value, does not mean
that the idea of uni-dimensional test is not working.
Sometimes you just need a more subtle test.
The other is that it was sort of striking
that you know we often think about
the importance of hiring
employees or admitting students based on potential.
Right? We are not looking at performance.
We are looking at potential. The question
is what might potential mean?
This is sort of one argument that it is saying
let us not look at their mean value,
let us look at their sort of top one
over K quantile value.
That's their upside potential.
And notice that K is scaled
to the size of the team that you are picking.
So if I am admitting 10 people I
am interested in the one tenth quantile.
If I'm admitting 100 people
I might be interested in [inaudible] quantile.
Again, in a world where we are optimizing the Max.
The Max as a particular thing you might want to optimize.
More generally, there is
a lot of interesting questions here,
some of which we have resolved some of which we have not.
So many questions about
given the way in which you evaluate sets,
is there a single uni-dimensional
test score you can apply?
And the answer is sometimes yes sometimes no.
You can construct situations where
there is no single number you can put on
each person's distribution that
actually gets you to within
a constant factor. All right.
So with that all wrapped up,
as I said this has been in part, a definitional activity.
Right? Going into a lot of the literature on fairness,
on diversity and selection, on bias selection.
And to think about some of the basic rules that
people are using trying to build models around them so
we can get some insights into what is going on.
In all these cases, I think,
what we are finding is you can get
quite complex behaviors from
relatively simple interventions.
Right? Things like the Rooney Rule,
things like selecting people so as to achieve the Max.
You can write in
very simple specifications that induce very,
very complicated behaviors.
And I think all of these lead to
interesting open questions when we
embed this into some kind of larger context.
In the end, the reason we introduce
an intervention like re-scores,
the reason we introduce an intervention
like the Rooney Rule,
is because we are thinking about
the dynamics of time going forward.
We are thinking about what the world is
going to look like five years
from now or 10 years from now if we implement this rule.
And, of course, dynamics over time are going
to introduce their own set of complex behaviors.
They are going to change the mix of people that we
see in the training and test sets that we work with.
They actually even, as the economists tell us,
change people's decisions about effort.
Because if you are being evaluated in
a biased world and there is bias
against you there is essentially a tax on your effort.
For every unit of effort you put in,
you are only getting back one minus
Epsilon reward because some of
that effort is actually being
lost to the bias against you.
And in that kind of a world,
people where this bias against are actually make
different decisions about effort.
They are actually going to
rationally potentially invest less effort.
Thereby, you know, sort of in
an unfortunate way, reinforcing the bias.
Right? Because of the bias,
they invest less effort and
that somehow confirms what people believe in
the bias and you get into this very
dangerous positive feedback loop.
The point being some of these interventions
can help break that feedback loop.
If we force people to look beyond
the bias they have that actually changes
the incentive calculation the people in the biased group
might make about investing effort and
actually break out of that.
So I think there are some very interesting questions
about the dynamics over time
both in the data that we see in
the incentives and that is going to,
I think, lead to a lot of interesting work
going forward. Thanks very much.
>> So, if I brought a,
especially given the challenges with
the [inaudible] folks and sensitivity analysis applied to this.
Do you have a sense for
various kinds of variants over what we you know really
slamming the results in
doing the job on them in terms of the clarity.
>> Yeah. So I think there is a.
>> If they have a question you might [inaudible].
>> The question is given
the difficulties in forming
accurate evaluations of people,
what happens when there is variance in the estimates?
Yeah, I guess I would say two things,
which is, notion variances operating at two levels.
First of all, all of
these cases we are talking with people
where what I see about them is
a distribution and
their true performance can be drawn from that definition.
So in some sense the models all build variants in.
And I think what is telling us is that the
heavier the tail and the power law
the more uncertainty I have about how
large the outlier is going to be.
So in a way these all sort of
almost start from the difficulty in forming...
Right,
all of these questions what would be different if I had
a deterministic evaluation of
the person being drawn description.
But then there is error in the preamble as.
Error in the parameters now is
sort of the second level of this.
Yeah. So I think again in some of
these cases I think what is happening
is it gets much
more challenging when there is large variance.
So most of the results that we have
basically say for sufficiently small errors,
we get roughly something that sort of changes
continuously and what I have been talking about here.
But it is an interesting question sort
of what is the threshold?
Like how much error can we tolerate
before qualitatively different behavior start happening?
Yeah and a lot of that is largely everybody.
>> Would it be practical in some cases to measure
Beta from a group and then
adjust your selection algorithms
instead of trying to fix the bias?
>> Yes, that's a nice question.
Can we measure Beta and then maybe use theta?
So there's two questions there.
One, is it plausible that we might be
able to measure some notion of Beta?
They are, potentially, and
we've thought a little about this.
Because to the extent that alpha and Delta are known,
the one missing thing,
and the selection rate is known,
the one missing thing there is Beta.
And in some sense, some of the behavioral work
has just started to get into
trying to estimate that quantity
mainly through lab experiments,
although we could do it with historical data.
Now the question, could we use that as an intervention?
We could say, what you should do
is just adjust your estimates by Beta,
that will correct for the bias.
I think the challenge there
is one very important thing about the Rooney Rule,
and actually everything in the analysis that we did,
is that it never requires people
to write down a number and manipulate the number.
All it ever does is ask people to make
ordinal comparisons between things.
And what that's consistent with is the fact that in
the field work on this
and also some of the lab work, it's very hard.
You would like to say we really care
about Google Scholar accounts
just as a pedagogical feature,
we don't necessarily really have that [inaudible] feature,
it's very hard to get people to say,
I'm going to look at a candidate and say,
future Google Scholar account is 12,000.
This one, future Google Scholar account, 14,000.
Okay, that person wins, but I'm going to
divide down by 1.2 because of bias.
Even before you ever got to the factor 1.2,
the idea that you're going to write down estimates,
that seems very hard for people to do.
And so what people are doing,
this is a model,
which is an abstraction barrier.
There are numbers operating below
the surface but all the people are ever
doing is making ordinal comparisons
and the intervention's operating there.
But I think it's very interesting in mapping.
>> Couldn't K be the intervention?
>> Couldn't?
>> K be intervention while you address the threshold?
>> So, how big should the shortlist be?
>> Yes.
>> So you could have an intervention that says,
you must continue interviewing people until you get to,
say, a candidate from group X.
>> No, I meant fixed K,
a bigger K with a probability distribution, [inaudible] the data.
Every year you pick
a different K and does it not give you information?
>> Obviously, if there's variation in K. Again,
that would be helpful in estimating Beta.
Again, I'm not sure that would help with
people trying to form their own numerical estimates.
I do think it's somehow key in
these models that the agents were
being modeled to make ordinal comparisons,
not numerical evaluations.
But, yes, if there were natural variation
in K. The Rooney Rule as
introduced so far says one out of K.
But there's presumably some actual parameter
like L out of K,
you can imagine an Lth order Rooney rule,
it says you must have L of
your K slots for your room reserved for a group.
And it's certainly not clear, in fact,
obviously it's not the case that one
is always the optimal number.
Our comparison here has been about one versus zero,
but one versus two versus three is very
special. I'll let you keep going.
>> So, in real life, if I'm going
to interview K people for a job,
that I'm going to give one person
a job and you alluded to it a little bit in
your graph of number of coaches.
And you said, "Oh, maybe recently we've
just decided that basically
the decision is made in advance
and I go through the motions of
interviewing K people which include
at least one underrepresented person."
Have you done any thinking
about is there something more we learn?
Presumably we do the interviewing
in a reasonable world to
learn something more about the candidates in
order to make a better informed decision,
have you done any analysis on hidden information and
how that might affect
this model of who then actually gets a job?
>> Yes. So, I think that's an interesting question.
As you can see in the discussion of the max at the end,
the way we're modelling theory
is there's a random variables of some distribution.
The act of interviewing now
materializes the value from it,
which is a very extreme form of the [inaudible] my uncertainty,
now I have a deterministic value.
You can imagine things
and some of this shows up in some of
the theoretical economics work on
discrimination in the labor market which
still uses very different models
than we're talking about.
Where for example there's a temporary
labor market and a permanent labor market,
so some nice work that Willy Hu
and Yiling Chen at Harvard just looked at recently,
where the temporary labor market gives
me better information about
the candidate but still not perfect.
And then that allows me to make
decisions about the permanent labor market.
That allows us to model of things such as,
I have a three-month internship program
in which I learn some information about the candidate.
But it's not that I now know everything.
And so, this is
an interesting staging effect
where I could invest different amounts of effort.
I could interview someone for one day or two days,
I could give them an internship for
two months or three months.
I could do a variety of things
that are going to come at different costs
and increase the amount of
information I have about this person or
reduce the uncertainty of this person.
So, I think some of the work in
that domain may also provide some insight into it [inaudible].
>> So, at the end,
you mentioned this idea of the max and
bringing it back to where you were earlier
in definitions of fairness,
calibration is expected value.
And you could transform that from,
instead of being 1-0 recidivism,
to actually estimation of harm
and take a max over a group where you
start matching based on features.
>> That's true, yes.
>> If we start thinking in this rank-based rule
and defaulting on loans,
it can be actually again
an unbounded variable of the amount lost.
How do we start thinking of fairness
in this role of ranking based on that?
>> Yes, that's an interesting question,
where we're doing some ordinal ranking.
Yes, we looked a little bit at this,
because ranking is actually a nice
intervention when I'm trying to say,
take an existing policy based on a human estimate of
risk and then using some algorithmic intervention.
So, one thing we've looked at
in the empirical work that we've been doing on
judges and bail is to say,
let's imagine a judge
that releases some number of people.
We'd like to use the risk tool
to sort them by predictive risk
and basically detain the ones
who are viewed as the most risky.
All right, and so you can
imagine some interaction between
the human decision maker and
the algorithm based on ranking,
where the human picks the set,
the algorithm ranks them and knocks the
most risky few out of it.
So, in that domain, we might then think
about the balance between different groups,
whether there's bias going on to different groups.
We might say, for example, of
this set that you knock out,
we need to keep some kind of approximate
composition between the groups.
It would be a kind
of Rooney Rule-like activity applied to
the algorithm's decision to knock people off
the top end of the max ranking.
But, I think there's a lot
of things you can potentially do,
because there's now this interaction
of the human decision maker's selection,
the algorithm's sorting, and some notion
of fairness as implied by the competition.
So, I think there are a lot of
interesting questions there that
one could potentially try modeling.
>> The expectation of max is
an interesting thing and it just reminds me.
With SAT, you can take it multiple
times and then you just report the max,
which sounds like weird ahead of time.
But given what you've found,
it's actually maybe a more correct thing to do than
just allow people to take it once
to get just an expected average value.
And what if they're similar,
like when 10 people interview the candidate,
perhaps we should do 10 really tough interviews
and take the max response.
If one person liked them,
we keep them, instead of averaging.
>> That actually is the mean.
>> [inaudible] I think we're [inaudible]
the average or the total or the sum or
whatever that the max is a different world.
>> Yes.
Now, I should say it's going to depend,
this is in a world where you're optimizing
for the max performance.
So, I think if you were going
to be hiring for a commune of
deep thinkers who were going to sit in
their rooms and have great idea and then out [inaudible]
come the best idea of all of them, then yes.
Qualitatively, if you have
a candidate who really wows somebody in one interaction,
you're like, that's what we're trying to select for.
Because when I pick K people,
and I just got to pick the max,
I'm going to get the top whatever K quantile somebody,
that's intuitively what's happening.
On the other hand, if you're picking, say,
for a research lab where
everybody is producing output and
we're evaluating something much more like
an LP norm closer to L1 or L2,
then I may not be optimizing for the max.
>> But the candidate selection being based on a max like,
say, Jerry's score or something
is actually the more correct.
>> That one I think, and you can
even argue other aspects of college applications.
So, candidates often try many different, say,
extracurricular activities and they
might try six or eight of them.
If they really succeed at one, that's what
they write about in their application essay.
And so implicitly, the system is
set up for them to select
the max of all the activities
that they try, maybe that makes sense.
You need to think of this
in completely different domains.
If you're on vacation for five days in
some new place and you're
going to eat five dinners at
five restaurants and you're hedonic experience,
the whole thing is going to be the
best of the five dinners that you had.
It says you should actually
evaluate Yelp reviews differently.
You should be looking at upside because in the end,
you remember the best of those five, not the median.
>> That's the meaning also remember.
>> The meaning also remember, yes.
>> Just the last question before we wrap up.
>> So, the first part,
you talked about this group calibration
as one of the alternatives.
So if you were to drop that,
what would you want to replace it with?
>> Well, in a way,
I want to keep the other two.
So I had three things that were mutual.
>> Keep those two and then drop calibration,
what do you replaced it with?
>> Well, I guess I should
check to make sure I understand the question.
But, I have three things right now,
calibration, balance for positive, balance for negative.
They're mutually incompatible
and sometimes I have to drop one.
So, one of the arguments
in this work of hard price and [inaudible] makes this argument.
If we drop calibration, then we're actually just right.
We don't have put anything back in because we're now just
barely going to satisfy that.
So we're gonna equalize the positives,
equalize negatives and we now have
lost all our degrees of freedom to do anything else.
And now we're just going to try
optimizing accuracy with it.
If I really were to put third condition back in,
I might get to some new impossibility result,
which I couldn't handle.
So, the argument that they make in their work is,
let's think about situations where
a calibration is not the important thing.
What's important is that people who have
similar behaviors should be given
similar scores and that that's really what fairness is,
and that's a compelling argument in some domains.
And so equalizing positives, equalizing negatives,
I've now exhausted my degrees
of freedom and the constraints in some sense.
>> Okay. Well, thanks very much, Chris.
>> Thanks.